kristin cavallari briefly returned this
season
how does she shake things up well she's
kristen cavallari
i think that alone speaks for itself
she's always been the
best character on the show and she
always brings something new to the table
so
i guess you have to wait and see what
she does she always comes with fire you
know that kristen comes in blazing
always
she is single again so could we
potentially see sparks fly
between you and her brandon
i mean kristen and i you know we we have
a past christian and i have dated the
past there's always gonna have
chemistry between kristen i love i love
kristen she's great you know she's
we get along and she's a lot of fun for
sure very much your answer again man
you know chemistry with all these people
brody you've really grown
i think if we'd had christian for like a
month there
you know some serious romances would
have gone down
you know i'm not gonna name names but i
felt that we just needed more time
maybe in the future there's there's a
lot of i felt it well brody did cop to
having chemistry with her too oh
okay yeah there we go he was like he
said they were about to start making out
on the rocks on the beach and i was like
what and so and he was this is off
camera serious talk i was like
maybe she should stay longer we can
explore this
yeah like why is she going back to
nashville like may watch the kids for a
couple more days
season three we're gonna let you play
matchmaker i think we should all go to
nashville where she doesn't have such a
rush
energy
[Music]
to being reunited
seeing her i think she has such a good
energy and she was such a part of this
group so having her come back was just
so nice and having her show up was at a
really good time especially
i feel like with audrina and i that was
taylor
sorry it was like for the three of us to
have some time and then for us to each
have a little time with her i love
kristen's energy and
when heidi and i went to nashville with
her we had the best time so having her
come back for a little bit was
exciting how does she shake things up oh
does she ever
i mean there's always fun to be had when
she walks into the room
and we definitely had some fun but
that's all i remember
i got a little drunk that night so i can
piece together moments of that evening
but i know it was lots of fun was it
just the one night
in mexico i think it was that she
returned no she's older than that i
think
she felt more than just not with all of
us collectively is she friendly with
everyone when she returns or is there
oh there's so much beating i'm just
kidding
she's a great per like i mean i'll say
this it was phenomenal to just we i
hadn't seen her in 10 years
so it was yeah it was incredible
i've heard a lot of people that i love
and that's not the brody i want to be
being a single mom dating i don't want
to end up with the wrong guy
there's been so much speculation about
like why we broke up